berlino sostituito vitale
benvenuti sogna solis
oggi nuova challenge se indovini lo farò
lo stesso copre bene
avete visto il nostro scorso video
essendovi di la parola lo metti nel live
and andate a vederlo dopo questo video
praticamente muore a volte a testa io di
tale dovremmo scrivere una parola sarà
praticamente ci saranno i trattini riale
uno decide la parola e mette tra tv e
l'altro deve indovinare in base dei
tratti né un numero di possibilità che
sarebbero come quelle l'impiccato quindi
devo disegnare l'impiccato euro ci
dovete uscire prima che ha praticamente
rally cliccato sui picchi non so se si è
capito qualcosa dalla strega terra la
spiegazione di evitare comunque come
gioco dell'impiccato che non dovrà dire
delle lettere se ci sono le lettere
allora andrò a scriverle se non ci sono
si crea l'impiccato di la testa il corpo
le braccia e le gambe dell'impiccato
terminato un'altra persona aperto e
prenderà niente invece di torino la
parola l'altra persona dovrà comprarla
mila so di un bel mi piace se volete
altre challenge del genere se volete la
salle copra tutto quello che disegni
versione cibo però è solo persone a 20
mila mi piace
faremo anche quella challenge mettetevi
comodi pop corn e iniziamo subito primo
turno tocca
non mi perdoni ma dobbiamo scrivere
niente allora mi è venuto in mente una
cosa
l'uno due tra dieci lettere mi pure la
vergogna non c'è quindi disegno la testa
dell'impiccato
mai y no la iii d italia sì c'è ci sono
due ricercati anche voi vi indovinare
vediamo chi riesce a indovinare se avete
le vostre risposte nei commenti
parola può essere di stile essere con
due gli pesa 8 12 la parola sbagliata ha
aperto all'inizio
che cos'è b non c'è
[Musica]
il corpo dell'impiccato ora mancano solo
le braccia le gambe avrei perso un'altra
lettera la hd ospedale mio bel calcio
grazie a 4 punti possibili tali sono
rimaste tre ancora la lily domodossola
ed è la terza lettera
il videoproiettore non può essere perché
non c'entra videotelefono dopo la penso
che sia videogiochi videogioco o
informativa videogioco
[Musica]
[Applauso]
oggi visto molto felice vita è un po
antico abita le piacciono questi
videogiochi nelle baracche si fa wrc 5
caspita si è candidato al mondo di rally
secondo round con altri dieci lettere
però sono due parole una ed assiste
l'altro da tre edifici
mi sento rinato ok iniziamo subito con
la prima lettera la adjani da allora
facciamo subito con la testa perché ma
senza che questa sarà molto difficile la
la testa proprio con l'alfabeto b
bologna per lei è qui l'inizio della
seconda letta cioè le marche che paron
esistono con tre lettere blu quindi
alimenti sono blu potrebbero www si no
il club di a che non andiamo c'è una
nota medico secondo me
e qualcosa tipo b quindi l non c'è sì ma
che farà una strana che cosa tipo
conchiglie killer l mi ricorda solo già
detto lei
sono due possibilità mrc c'è non è
merende vero quello che cavolo di parola
lì
voi avete indovinato ma non agosto
questa parole troppo strada ti si dai
vasi siamo nella direzione giusta perché
dica mistero ministero f si dividerà
mystery
[Musica]
l'inglese ha detto attiva che mi sembra
di comprarmi e quello bene andiamo
subito a serle
[Musica]
io sento la mia ho scelto due perché
erano piccoline e quindi in realtà
sarebbero mettere i minis box
una è di the nightmare before christmas
è uno dei miei film preferiti fatemi
sapere se lo avete mai troppa e l'altro
di stringer james che è una delle mie
serie preferite
vediamo riapriamo l'inter ad aprire
questa visser i boss di nightmare before
christmas fatemi stato nei miei commenti
se lo avete visto io adoro questo film
io spero che mi capiti object skeleton
dürer lunelli sono carinissimi
ma anche il cagnolino fantasmino e super
carino vediamo così capita
[Musica]
molto contenta perché una delle più
carine se li è bellissimo che trucchetti
super dolci e comunque ho fatto a super
bene perché il vestito è uguale sì mi
piace tantissimo sono super contenta che
ho trovate le wow boxing stranger times
io spero che vi capiti il mio
personaggio preferito
altrimenti mi piacerebbe anche in
versione mago ma che è andata davvero
molto carino
vediamo un po avevo trovato lucas non mi
riconosco il nome comunque fatto super
bene è molto carino quindi che ci sono i
personaggi che ho trovato nelle misteri
po troppo carini aprire le mistery box
che a me critica insieme altissima ma
lunghissimo ho fatto non ho contato
quante lettere sono ormai 42 34 di cos'è
7 8 9 10 lettere
vediamola così vitale non c'è ma la
memoria nemmeno ai lacci di como
lacie all'inizio e poi provate a
indovinare a 3 c è perché mi piace tanto
di già si è già a prof
non sono sicuro c'è una t t di torino
testi vicino c'è anche ci sono anche
delle o giusto per essere preciso
ora è facilissimo dai provato indovinare
nella capitale
[Musica]
il giovane cioccolato cioccolato 1 ora
16 linee 1
uscite
mentale ha scelto questo cioccolato
fondente perché il cioccolato preferito
di vitale è quello fondente scrivete voi
nei commenti qual è il vostro lato
perché no perché il secondo ha detto che
quello che quella che indovina di
coccole indovinato romanzo vediamo
fantastico bellissimo ma nion tenuto
conto e questa è la chiusero nello stato
romanzi tutto contornato da quando
voglio io devo indovinare io sono super
feriti in base a quello che ho capito
che ti piace o io ho messo una delle
lettere qui che sono molto difficili
sono 15 ma ne vale la pena
ma previste per farmelo difficile a
medie trovato facilissimo il cioccolato
tre parole
iniziamo subito col a di anita volevo
dire che sono quattro parole sul tavolo
così però quatraro una una decisone di
numeri che quindi sono quattro parole
però misure ci sono i numeri non
indovinerà ormai ha detto la mia vita
qui dove sono state c'è la linearità
tutti tranquilli
berna in un anno indovinato ben è
utilissimo sapere che la e l'ultima
parola nell'ultima lettera oraria facile
gestire tutte le stelle
allora prova a dire le lettere in base a
cosa che mi circonda perché lì c'è una
pianta una pianta verde quindi piccola
vi facciamo subito la testa a testa
finale la testa si rivede voi avete
indovinato philippe iata cioè aspetta
perché ce n'è anche un'altra persona che
farò è come viene in mente papera ora
vediamo cosa qua intorno la ruota
r cioè caspita mi sta andando proprio
bene questa volta
il tavolo e stava andando troppo bene
53 possibilità che sono rimaste vedove
di sprechi è impossibile non ce l'ha
però mai meno male perché è quello che
ho scelto guarda bene non sta lettera la
modifica non c'è non c'è non c'erano
giannetta asilo nido a detta di verde o
di otranto che mi viene in mente impo
potevo proprio rob prova che così è
proprio lì potevo professionale aspetta
è prova prova rotta roma pro l'ha mai
vista questa parola brutta cosa meno
male niente enne di napoli cioè bene on
phone go pro max max minimente roma
[Musica]
no no non può essere e di empoli 3 è una
parola in inglese
no non ci credo non vi diremo che fosse
uno scherzo carrobbio h cioè four cross
e di volo cioè dopo ma le spese tutte ci
credo ai font romas etò per chiamata del
corpo può sbagliare
il nuovo aspetta prima c'era 10 poi nel
sito 1 dopo il 10
mi sembra di sì quindi sarà il 12 adesso
perché il 10 è uscito due anni fa 11 12
però non mi ricordo che fosse un posso
controllare non mi ricordo che si fosse
mai che se un sito l'iphone 11ma
numerico non è di avere 12 15 roma 15 15
11 grande formato zip roma
[Musica]
no non è mostrata la fine ho scelto per
lo bianco era indeciso chi è però quello
bianco ma qualora la troppo era un po
giallo breve professor bianchi sono
super contento aprirlo
[Musica]
e cruciale bianchissimo allucinante smr
incredibile è pulitissimo non durerà il
nuovo ci sono i soliti foglietti il
caricatore le cuffie e il cavo insomma
non c'è nient'altro ovviamente è group
il retro e bianco ma è opaco invece
l'altro iphone se non sbaglio è il
contrario è lucido e la camera e opaca
quando c'è la camera e lucida e
retropalco comunque il calore mi piace
un sacco
scrivetemi se secondo voi è meglio
quello ora o quello verde immaginate se
vita sono le cuffie sono sempre le
solite e il capo ed ecco challenge se
indovini la parola te la compri
lasciatemi tasse se volete vederne altre
e ora vi lasciamo 4 caselline triplicare
per vedere le nostre altre challenge
cliccare su cui hanno preferito evitare
ciao
[Musica]